Greece has reached a deal with its
international creditors for a third
bailout that will secure its finances
for the next three years it's reportedly
worth 85 billion euros and includes a 10
billion-euro cash injection to shore up
the Greek banking system in return the
Athens government has agreed not to
spend more than it raises in income the
commission team has worked day and night
to deliver on the euro summit statement
and on the expectations of the Eurogroup
this work was done hand-in-hand with the
IMF the ECB and the ESM on the ground
the institutions and the Greek
authorities achieved an agreement in
principle on a technical basis and talks
are still ongoing on finalizing details
earlier in the program we spoke to
Philip Pangalos a journalist in Athens
the good news is that they have reached
an agreement it's 86 billion euros after
marathon talks that went on from Monday
into Tuesday the next step of course
will be putting it through Greece's
Parliament which goes tomorrow thursday
with a view to having it voted through
before Eurogroup meeting of finance
ministers on friday now the problem here
of course is Prime Minister Alexis
tsipras and his radical left syriza
government were elected at the start of
the year on a pledge not to have more
austerity and of course there's lots
more austerity in this agreement they're
going to be rises in VA tea on Greek
islands there's going to be rises in
taxation for farmers which is going to
be pretty unpopular and there's going to
be a cut in early retirement these are
obviously your forms that need to be
made but there will no doubt be
resistance from the hardline isn't the
so-called left platform within syriza
it's likely be passed again with the
backing of pro-european opposition MPs
but it's going to be tough also there's
a certain amount of disbelief in some of
the other European capitals especially
amongst more hardliners like the Germans
who feel that some of the details on
this agreement is still a little bit
vague and the other matter that we
should be reminded horses this is more
austerity this is going to be
recessionary measures Greece's slip back
into recession the economy's expected
contract by at least three percent this
year and again in 2016 this
an economy that's already contracted by
morn the chords in the previous five
years so there's going to be tough
measures and there are certain issues
that had to be clear that one of the key
issues is the Greek banks which of
course since capital controls were
introduced at the start of July Greek
economy just got into three people Greek
savers have taken their money out from
the Greek banks and also non-performing
loans are skyrocketing as companies fall
further behind an individual's so the
banks have to be recapitalized it's
estimated they need something like 25
billion euros and also the whole big big
question about Greece's debt and whether
it's sustainable and I think the answer
that is the isn't people like the IMF
saying they won't come on board this new
bailout unless Greece's debt is made
sustainable and there's a certain amount
of resistance from the Germans on that
phone so a lot of hurdles from mr. to
you but I still a long way to go Philip
and I lost there in Athens